bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés ce soir
nous allons évoquer avec nos invités un
sujet qui a fait parler beaucoup de lui
ces derniers jours et ce n'est pas prêt
de s'arrêter il s'agit évidemment de la
déchéance de nationalité la semaine
passée l'assemblée nationale adopté le
deuxième article sur le projet de loi
constitutionnelle il prévoit d'inscrire
dans la constitution la déchéance de
nationalité pour les personnes
condamnées pour terrorisme
une mesure voulue par françois hollande
après les attentats du 13 novembre à
paris alors faut-il inscrire à cette
mesure dans la constitution doit s
appliquer à tous les français est ce
possible selon le droit français et les
normes internationales pour répondre à
ces questions
pierre déjean président de la ligue des
droits de l'homme des yvelines olivier
parent et jacquot secrétaire
départemental d'europe écologie les
verts flora sabbagh présidente des
jeunes républicains des yvelines et
fabienne jo professeur de droit à
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
bonsoir à tous et commençons par vous
cette émission avec vous olivier paris
jacquot secrétaire départemental je
lisais des verts vous êtes opposés à
cette déchéance de nationalité inscrit
dans la constitution pourquoi tout
simplement pourquoi vous êtes opposés à
cela
déjà on peut remarquer que si on discute
avec des amis avec des collègues ce
n'est pas nécessairement la priorité
je pense qu'on attend beaucoup plus de
choses à la fois par rapport aux
événements qui ont eu lieu l'année
dernière mais de manière générale dans
la société
c'est vraiment pas le sujet sur lequel
on aurait envie que la représentation
nationale passe du temps en ce moment
que le gouvernement passe du temps en ce
moment donc il ya déjà un problème de
deux priorités
après sur le principe même
cette déchéance de nationalité comme
elle a été présentée après ça a été
légèrement revu par le gouvernement
était quand même quelque chose qui était
plutôt de nature à diviser les français
alors que le discours initial de
françois hollande à versailles et elle
voulait plutôt rassembleur et donc on
est plutôt en train dé stigmatiser les
binationaux par exemple oui mais c'était
dans et si c'était bon à la limite dans
la continuité c'est mémé l'idée c'était
quand même d'arriver à réunir tous les
français à souder un peu la nation
autour de valeurs démocratiques autour
de valeurs qui sont plutôt de nature à
faire que on vivre mieux ensemble on
comprenne ce qui s'est passé et on
agisse correctement là on se retrouve
face à une mesure qui initialement était
très très stigmatisante donc qui a été
qui a été atténuée dont beaucoup de gens
s'accordent à reconnaître qu'elle n'aura
aucune efficacité donc elle est
symbolique donc c'est un symbole
et en plus un symbole qui divise donc
vraiment c'est pas tout à fait le moment
de faire des choses comme ça flora
sabbagh présidente des jeunes
républicains et vine vous vous êtes pour
alors en réponse à ce que les vendeurs
peut-être olivier paribas est votre
point de vue avoue personnel sur cette
question oui tout à fait moi je suis
pour je pense que c'est une mesure de
bon sens qui a été adoptée dans de
nombreux autres pays d'ailleurs c'est
également la position qui a été adopté
par le bureau politique des républicains
le 6 janvier dernier
vous dites que c'est une mesure qui
clivent énormément moi j'ai vu des
sondages disaient que 85% de la
population approuvé cette mesure de
déchéance de nationalité
je pense que la sécurité des français
exigent un débat loin de tout calcul
politique et c'est un débat qui exige la
clarté oui il ya eu des divisions au
sein même des républicains au sein même
de votre parti on n'est pas forcément
d'accord non plus sur la question tout à
fait mais il ya des débats dans les deux
dans les deux camps politiques que ce
soit au parti socialiste et j'imagine
que chez europe ecologie les verts
également il ya du débat mais nous nous
avons une ligne qui a été exprimé par
nicolas sarkozy notre chef de parti et
elle a été votée par les deux tiers des
députés à l'assemblée
l'idée au départ de pour françois
hollande c'est de ces de répondre aux
attaques terroristes est ce que c'est ce
genre de mesure qui répondent vous savez
rechercher l'effet dissuasif et médias
je pense et se condamner à l'inaction
soyons clairs fichiers se renseigner
mobiliser des forces de police n'a
jamais empêché un terroriste de passer à
l'acte et je pense que pour gagner la
guerre nous avons vraiment besoin
d'alliés la puissance militaire à la
force du symbole et aujourd'hui c'est ce
qui a voulu été exprimée je pense par
cette mesure
alors dans le détail pour ceux qui nous
regardent les députés se sont exprimés
sur ce point précisément le 9 février
ils sont 330 de avoir pris part au vote
sur 577 députés en tout et 162 ont voté
pour 148 contre et 22 se sont abstenus
et si on regarde le vote des députés
yvelinois là aussi c'est très divisée 5
pour 5 contre et une abstention et que
ce soit au sein de la droite de la
gauche pas d'unité au sein du parti
socialiste par exemple benoît hamon a
voté contre
quand françoise descamps crosnier a voté
pour et au sein des républicains si on
prend deux exemples assez rapidement
henri guaino contre david douillet pour
pierre déjean ou pas ça vous quel est
votre point de vue à vous président
yvelinois de la ligue des droits de
l'homme sur cette question de la
déchéance de nationalité est ce que déjà
il faut l'inscrire dans la constitution
d'abord je crois qu'il faut peut-être
rappeler effectivement que cette
déchéance de la nationalité qui nous est
proposé de l'aveu même de ce qu'il
propose n'aura aucune efficacité
donc c'est un peu se moquer du monde de
proposer quelque chose dont on sait que
ce sera totalement inefficace salon
d'honneur valls a dit que c'était plutôt
symbolique n'a pas forcément dit que ça
ne serait pas efficace
alors je sais pas si manuel valls en
personne l'a dit mais effectivement dans
son cadet cependant dans son camp pardon
et parmi ses proches
ça a été dit et puis effectivement c'est
le cas de tout le monde
qu'est ce que ça peut avoir comme
influence sur quelqu'un qui aurait vous
qui voudraient commettre un attentat de
se dire battra je vais peut-être pas le
faire parce que je vais risques et
d'autres plaident français ont vraiment
se moquer du monde que de dire ça
donc c'est totalement inefficace sert à
quoi c'est vrai les attentats sans vol
s'envoler symbole de quoi il ya un
besoin c'est vrai que les symboles
saison peut dire au timor leste la
colombe c'est le symbole la paix bon
d'accord mais la déchéance de
nationalité c'est le symbole de quoi on
lui symbolique non dit pas de quoi alors
bon tout ça et cotait je ne sais pas
pourquoi le gouvernement fait ça il a
ramassé ça dans le programme de
l'extrême droite puisque ça fait partie
des choses qui sont longtemps depuis
longtemps prôné par par cette extrême
droite ou par la droite extrême
d'ailleurs ce qui revient à peu près au
même
et on ne sait pas très bien pourquoi il
fait ça c'est voilà donc ensuite qu'est
ce que ça va provoquer qu'est ce que ça
va provoquer on va retirer la
nationalité française à qui ça serait à
des gens qui ont de nationalité puisque
la voilà aujourd'hui donc ça va lire la
batterie alors que ont créé deux
catégories de français
il ya ceux qui sont uniquement français
et ceux qui ont deux nationalités
bon et puis retiré la société française
c'est quoi bon créer des étrangers c'est
tout mais ça résout à tout ça résout
absolument pas le propre le problème et
puis et puis et puis bah les les
attentats qui ont été commis récemment
en novembre et les derniers il n'est
plus le plus meurtrier
il a été commis par des fauteuils
peut-être arrêter le s'interroger ce
serait beaucoup plus efficace de
s'interroger pour savoir qu'est ce qui à
un moment donné peut amener des citoyens
français à commettre un attentat de
cette nature là or justement le manuel
valls dont vous parliez tout à l'heure a
dit qu'il ne fallait pas chercher donc
il se condamne lui-même à la puissance
comme il veut masquer son impuissance à
il nous sort quelque chose pour enfumer
puis
puis dire bah tiens on parlera d'autre
chose fabienne jour faisons un point
déjà sur la législation française est ce
que en france on entend beaucoup de
choses sur la question parfois tout et
son contraire parfois même des bêtises
est ce qu'aujourd'hui le droit français
permet de retirer sa nationalité à
quelqu'un
oui tout à fait on a déjà essayé pour ça
je pense que il est important de faire
encore des débats sur la déchéance de la
nationalité c'est que les gens sont pas
bien informés quand on dit qu'à 80% ou
85% des français qui sont pour
j'aimerais savoir si parmi ces personnes
qui se sont exprimées pour l'inscription
de la déchéance de la nationalité dans
la loi dans la constitution il sait
personne savait donc que la déchéance de
nationalité existe déjà
je vais pas vous demander d'ouvrir un
code civil mais vous pouvez aller c'est
l'article 25 25 et 25 1 il ya plusieurs
cas de perte de nationalité et en ce qui
concerne la déchéance donc là la perte
la plus symbolique la sanction
véritablement puisqu'il ya des pertes
qui peuvent être volontaire mais là
c'est une perte prononcée par le
gouvernement on a déjà tout ce qu'il
faut dans le code civil pour permettre à
l'administration de déchoir une personne
qui a une autre nationalité aujourd'hui
ça serait aujourd'hui le droit français
permet cela uniquement sur les gens qui
ont acquis la nationalité française et
aujourd'hui enfin avec le projet s'il
était voté adopté au congrès ce serait
les français n'est en tout cas ceux qui
sont nés français binationaux
c'est ça la grande nouveauté alors on
remplace une discrimination par une
autre discrimination puisque on va au
lieu de distinguer entre les français
qui ont acquis la nationalité français
et ceux qui sont de naissance français
on va distinguer entre les binationaux
et les monos nationaux l'expression est
pas belle mais c est parlante l image et
or ce qu'il faut aussi savoir c'est que
la plurinationalité la binationalité ça
pas beaucoup de sens
il ya des personnes qui ne peuvent pas
être binational tout simplement parce
que dans leur pays d'origine
la binationalité n'existe pas je veux
pas dire de bêtise j'ai pas vérifié
avant de venir mais il me semble me
souvenir qu'en chine par exemple la vie
nationale il n'existe pas donc si un
chinois acquiert la nationalité
française il ne sera que français
puisque en chine on refusera de le voir
comme comme chinois donc lui il pourra
pas si on a les réserves aux hobbies
nationaux quel que soit son comportement
il ne pourra pas être déchu de la
nationalité française
alors que dans les pays du maghreb c'est
vrai quand on tolère s'est passé pas
très admis mais on tolère la double
nationalité
flora sa vague qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ces inquiétudes sur ce
sentiment aussi d'inégalités de créer
dans le schuss pas que ça va créer de
qualité puisque comme on l'a dit cette
déchéance de nationalité been pour les
bi nationaux existent déjà mais pour
ceux qui ont acquis donc la nationalité
française depuis moins de dix ans ou 15
ans dans les cas de terrorisme
donc là c'est juste rétablir une
situation d'égalité pour les binationaux
des français vous parliez d'inefficacité
c'est aussi je pense que c'est un
argument fallacieux quand on sait tous
les tous les tous les avantages que
procure la nationalité française que ce
soit des avantages civique ou sociaux je
pense que nous avons besoin de symboles
forts la république ne doit plus reculés
et je vais vous prendre un exemple qui
peut justifier que soit de mera soit
encore française quant à la cantèle et
elle a fui en syrie pour continuer le
jihad
je pense que nous avons besoin d'envoyer
des symboles forts à nos concitoyens
quelqu'un qui prend les armes contre son
pays quelqu'un qui s'exclut de lui même
de la communauté nationale ne mérite pas
d'être français olivier par ailleurs
pourquoi faire une différence entre
quelqu'un qui a une autre nationalité
est quelqu'un qui est français des gens
qui ont une autre nationalité quand même
en france il y en à 3,7 millions et je
sais pas depuis qu'on parle de cette
déchéance de la nationalité pour les
binationaux tout le monde
rencontre autour de chez lui des amis
dont il ne savait même pas et dont il ne
s'intéressait même pas au fait qu'ils
puissent être bi national je comprends
pas en quoi c'est pourquoi ces personnes
là serait plus condamnable ou plus
exclu de la nationalité française que
d'un français qui prend les armes et se
retourne comme alors que vous avez des
questions que dans le projet de loi
présenté aux députés dans un premier
temps puis bientôt aux sénateurs à
partir du 12 mars il n'y a plus cette
notion de binationalité est ce que c'est
de nature aussi à vous rassurer sur vos
inquiétudes
le fait qu'on retire ce mot précisément
du projet de loi alors le fait de
retirer ce mot là c'est plutôt une bonne
chose mais ça reste quand même ambigu
parce que d'un côté on dit que
effectivement c'est la déchéance pour
tous de là à dire que c'est un progrès
est faux on peut on peut en discuter
mais après il ya aussi le fait que l'on
dit que par ailleurs on va pas créer des
apatrides
donc ça veut dire aussi que on reste
quand même sur les gens que l'on va
pouvoir déchoir de la nationalité
française sans pour autant qu'il n'est
pas de nationalité tiers des gens le
fait qu'on retire vie nationale du
projet de loi
bien entendu c'est effectivement si on
peut le retirer qu'il ya quelqu'un qui a
une autre nationalité c'est bien qu'on
vise les bi ou tri je sais pas si ça
existe nationaux donc 50 cent est pauvre
c'est encore un est un écran de fumée
et puis je voudrais quand même préciser
une chose c'est que dans le terrorisme
qu'est ce qui est condamnable c'est le
crime seulement le crémeux et en faisant
une cette déchéance de nationalité comme
condamnation en fait ce qu'on condamne
c'est le fait d'être un étranger et les
abats seconds to know si price est pas
admissible
oui rappelons quand même puisque on nous
dit qu'il faut des histoires de l'année
c'est des françaises les gens qui
prennent les armes contre leur pays
après tout dans le débat philosophique
ça peut se concevoir rappelons quand
même qu'il ya quand même on va dire 75
ans est bien un certain nombre de
français ont pris les armes contre leur
pays un général de gaulle par exemple et
tous ceux qui l'accompagnaient et bien
que moi je suis désolé mais je préfère
le général de gaulle pour marcher le pet
à fabienne joue sur la question des
apatrides
aujourd'hui là aussi on entend tout et
son contraire il ya même des élus de
gauche qui ont proposé de la déchéance
de nationalité pour tous les français
jean marie le guen jean vincent placé
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est applicable
ça pour tous les français imaginons la
déchéance de nationalité ou alors la
france comme le dit manuel valls ne peut
pas créer des apatrides
disons que si on crée des apatrides ce
sera moi une rupture dans nos valeurs
républicaines puisque quand même depuis
depuis des décennies le droit français
le droit de la nationalité française
s'est construit pour éviter des
situations d'apatridie donc quand une
personne n'est sur les territoires
français et qui n'est pas susceptible
d'avoir une autre nationalité
on lui donne la nationalité française
justement dans l'objectif de lutter
contre contre l'apatridie par ailleurs
on a beaucoup invoqué des textes
internationaux qui conférerait une sorte
qui proclamerait un droit à la
nationalité sont nos droits de l'homme
et la déclaration universelle des droits
de l'homme après la ensuite 45 48 48
cela je me dis qu'ils sont fiers des
gens remercie la garantie là on a une
convention européenne indus dans le
cadre du conseil de l'europe de 1997 sur
la nationalité qui qui évite aussi qui
cherche à éviter les situations
d'apatridie mais l'argument il n'est pas
très fort parce que la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme de
1948 n'est pas d'effet direct
donc c'est un texte de principe mais on
peut pas très long voilà c'est pas
contraignant et puis la fameuse
convention de 1997 sur la nationalité
on n'a pas ratifié la france ne l'a pas
ratifié simplement il ya quand même dans
le droit non écrit donc le droit non
contraignant même bien même de plus en
plus le droit un peu mou il ya quand
même cette idée qu'il est très très
mauvais de créer des apatrides
jusqu'à présent seulement possible mais
là c'est pas contraire aux textes qui
nous lie c'est pas impossible mais ça
correspond pas à nos valeurs
flora flora sa bague pour la droite ça
c'est une ligne rouge fin d'un matt read
nantes vraiment je pense que créer des
apatrides c'est ce n'est pas conforme à
nos valeurs notre idée est à nouveau
engagements internationaux et je pense
que vraiment c'est la ligne n y pas ne
pas dépasser
le texte va arriver au sénat je le
disais bientôt le 12 mars les sénateurs
de droite comme les députés de droite ne
sont pas forcément d'accord sur la
question que doivent faire les sénateurs
us qui doivent projet bloquer ce projet
puisqu'il n'est plus conforme à ce qu'il
est et on va dire proposé le 16 novembre
ou alors il doit ils doivent tout faire
pour qu'il soit adopté
écoutez ce sera à délibérer en bureau
politique des républicains si le texte a
été trop dénaturer de par le texte
initial je pense que une large majorité
de sénateurs s'abstiendront nous
voterons contre olivier paréja vous
souhaitiez réagir non toujours moi je
pense que les jeux je crois que vous
avez des signes de la main c'est nous à
nous tous mais je pense que les
sénateurs doivent rejeter ce texte là et
alors j'imagine que la majorité ne sera
pas ne sera pas possible au sénat vu sa
configuration mais mais il faudrait que
ça s'arrête c'est pas la peine d'aller
inscrire dans la constitution quelque
chose comme ça la constitution la
modifie pas d qui a eu une attaque
terroriste c'est quelque chose qui est
quand même un socle
elle n'a pas bougé depuis longtemps je
vous laisse dire depuis combien de temps
je n'oserais pas à ce point là il a
jamais été inscrit dans la constitution
donne ma disposition sur la nationalité
inscrit dans la constitution
ce qu'il faut vous dire aussi sur le
point strictement juridique c'est que le
conseil d'état a été consulté en
décembre sur 7 sur ce projet de loi
il a rendu un avis favorable mais un
avis extrêmement embarrassés ainsi on
est un peu derrière les lignes il est
soumis après le pain je veux pas je veux
pas interpréter ce qu'on fait
les juges du conseil d'état mais on a
quand même l'impression qu'ils sont
sentis un peu obligé de dire oui à sa
décision politique c'est une question
politique il ya le débat paulina c'est
pour ça donc
alors qu'on aurait pu espérer un débat
juridique wii se rendent et un sur un
tel débat qui divise finalement temps la
classe politique à droite à gauche c'est
ce qu'on peut imaginer aussi un
référendum pour demander aux français
puisque finalement c'est la constitution
de tous les français de la république
française de tous les français des
citoyens français ce qu'on peut leur
demander leur avis qu'est ce que vous en
pensez par exemple vous olivet paréja un
référendum sur une question si
importante que ça en tout cas moi je me
pose quand même la question on en débat
beaucoup mais je ne suis pas sûr que ça
soit si important que ça pour les
français je ne suis pas sûr que quand on
rencontre des gens dans la rue et qu'on
leur parle de ce sujet là ils peuvent
avoir un avis je dis pas le contraire
mais est ce que c'est vraiment la
question qu'il faut aller leur poser
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on n'est pas sur
un faux problème est ce qu'on n'est pas
sur des manoeuvres politiques qui
continuent à décrédibiliser les
politiques alors que il ya beaucoup plus
de choses à faire ailleurs
donc le référendum je ne vois pas
l'intérêt
pierre déjean à référendum est ce que ce
serait propice aux de vos attentes
démocratiques je suis pour faire ces
bandes annonces très compétents dans mon
homme dans ma fonction pour dire s'il
faut ou pas un référendum
en tout cas le référendum c'est une
manipulation extrêmement délicate
c'est être tranché par oui ou par non un
problème qui est infiniment complexe et
puis l'air de rien ça nécessite quand
même une chose c'est que pour choisir
les citoyens devaient éclairer date est
éclairée or aujourd'hui le débat il n'a
pas tellement lieu il a lieu ici tant
mieux et je ne peux que
vous en féliciter dans les grands médias
nationaux c'est plutôt le bourrage de
crâne pour le projet et puis c'est tout
les opposants de s'exprime pratiquement
jamais de temps en temps on voit un
pseudo débat
on ne veut pas dire où elle est peu
importe parce que c'est vraiment des
pseudo-débats mais centre des gens qui
se connaissent bien qui se répand depuis
longtemps et puis qui se dit ce
spécialiste de la chose sans connaître
rien n'a rien et pour ça les rend adams
a posé beaucoup plus de problèmes que ça
n'apporterait de solution il faut un
débat havrais et éclairé tout le monde
avant de vous donner la parole à sa
bague pour les pour les républicains est
ce que femme douce c'est possible de
faire un référendum sur une question qui
touche à la constitution les
modifications de la constitution peut
peut être fait par voie de référendum
mais je suis pas du tout spécialiste de
droit de nick et je suis pas politique
non plus donc là je vais pas m'avancer
sur un terrain glissant d' mais c'est
possible c'est possible mais est-ce que
c'est opportun
je crois franchement franchement que les
français ont d'autres d'autres choses
d'autres préoccupations et pour avoir
raboté bientôt pour d'autres enjeux le
risque c'est de poser une question et
d'obtenir une autre question parce que
le sujet est quand même très techniques
sur le plan juridique
donc c'est un sujet qui n'est pas simple
et on a vu une balle le les sondages
d'opinion ont quand même donné un 4e 25
% d'opinions favorables contre la
déchéance de nationalité et je faut
savoir comment sont faits ces pseudos
sondages aussi parce qu'ils sont
bricolées sont lamentables une
caractéristique en débat peut-être mais
c'est important de le savoir que le
saison d'âge ce sondage là ne veulent
rien dire parce qu'ils ne respectent pas
le chasser les normes de sondages selon
vous on va pas des modes de ça pendant
très longtemps juste pour vous entendre
avoir votre avis sur un autre son autre
sujet la déchéance de citoyenneté c'est
une idée qui a été notamment émises par
jean marc ayrault qui l'a ensuite
enterré le nouveau ministre des affaires
étrangères on perdrait le droit de voter
et de se présenter à une élection est ce
que ça ça correspond plus à vos attentes
par exemple olivier par les ja suis pas
sûr c est peut-être il la charge
symbolique est peut-être moins élevés
mais par contre je suis pas sûr que ça
résout plus le problème est ce qu'il
faudrait s que carrément arrêter ce
débat là est passé à autre chose mais
probablement probablement on en l2 puis
2012 à la quatrième loi sur sur le
terrorisme il ya eu la loi sur le
renseignement il n'y a pas si longtemps
que ça on est en train de rentrer dans
une espèce d'escaladé qui n'a pas prouvé
son efficacité
donc au bout d'un moment faut peut-être
se poser problème c'est qu'il va
s'attaquer aux vrais problèmes escalade
des faits force est de constater qu'ils
aient une escalade des faits aussi
puisqu'une de satan et c'est l'attenté
est-ce que répondre à la violence par
une violence symbolique alors que on
peut aussi se poser des questions
pourquoi des jeunes qui sont français et
qu'ils soient binationaux ou simplement
français comme s'était dit tout à
l'heure ont commis ces actes là où est
le problème ou et le le le besoin social
qui était derrière quand on a tous des
fils élan janvier l'année dernière en
disant je suis charlie il fallait aussi
dire pour éviter ces problèmes là il ya
peut-être des choses à faire dans un
certain nombre de quartiers d
accompagnement socio des accompagnements
d'éducation qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas
les moyens nécessaires quand vous parlez
de justement de choses à faire
concrètement qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour vous pour lutter contre
contre les problèmes liés aux taureaux
terrorisme en france
je pense qu'on a un gros travail de
déconstruction de l'imaginaire des
terroristes pourquoi ils font ça comment
ils enrôlent des gens et ça ça se fait
pas en escaladant la violence en prenant
des mesures symboliques de déchéance de
nationalité
c'est vraiment en allant et il ya des
associations qui le font en allant
déconstruire la réalisation qui peut se
passer dans certaines dans certaines
franges de la population française et ça
c'est intéressant et c'est là dessus
qu'il faudrait travailler plus tôt flora
sa bague sur cette même question telle
est la priorité aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment la déchéance de nationalité ou
c'est un point parmi tant d'autres pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
vous savez si l'état islamique a
progressé c'est à la fois par ses
conquêtes militaires que par des actes
symboliques et on l'a vu à plusieurs
reprises et donc je pense que nous aussi
comme je les dis nous devons allie la
puissance militaire à la femme se
positionne par rapport à l'état
islamique
il faut avoir une réponse adaptée la
république ne doit plus reculés et la
singularité de la droite républicaine à
laquelle j'appartiens
c'est de dire les choses sans détour
c'est de regarder la réalité en face les
français qui trahissent la france ne
mérite pas d'être français fier des gens
effectivement le dirigeant de l'état
islamique doivent être absolument
terrorisé par cette déchéance de
nationalité française de paniquer tout à
fait bon faut être sérieux faut être
sérieux
alors nous est ce que le débat doit se
poursuivre ou non pour nous la réponse
est non nous nous avons écrit à tous les
parlementaires les députés les sénateurs
ont enfin une lettre individuelle du
département bien sûr pour leur demander
de ne pas voter cette loi et de ne pas
l'inscrire dans la constitution et j
nous parce que nous l'ont fait en tant
que les droits de l'homme mais nous ne
sommes pas seuls nous avons participé à
la création d'une coordination qui
s'appelle nous ne serons pas www nous ne
céderons pas point org
je vous invite à visiter à signer la
pétition mais attendu et vous verrez que
ya plus de 300 organisations qui sont
dans cette danse est tecla et et des
plus grands des partis des syndicats des
associations
non nous ne céderons pas il faut
absolument mettre ce débat aux
oubliettes
fabienne jour vous aurez la conclusion
de ces débats lourde tâche de conclure
ce débat merci je voudrais moi revenir
sur cette peine la dignité
c'est en effet un moindre mal par
rapport à la déchéance de nationalité
parce qu'on voit que si on commence à
toucher au droit de la nationalité on va
créer des nouvelles discriminations y en
a certaines on en crée d'autres n'y a
pas de bonne solution on peut pas
trouver une bonne solution en touchant
au droit de la nationalité aujourd'hui
donc essayons de trouver autre chose et
en effet si on veut une mesure
symbolique la peine d' indignés taylor
s'était pas de l'expression vous avez
utilisé enfin sa conscience de la
déchéance des histoires et du thé mais
bon enfin déjà on a eu dans le passé
cette cette idée de peine d'indignité et
en effet on prive d'un certain nombre de
droits civiques le condamner et c'est
sans doute mieux de toute façon une fois
qu'il est déchu de sa nationalité si on
expulse rien n'empêche de revenir pour
commettre ça sert à quoi d'être être
déchu de sa nationalité
on aura l'occasion probablement
d'échangés une nouvelle fois la semaine
prochaine fois merci beaucoup à tous les
cas d'avoir participé à ce débat c'est
la fin de ce sept huit sociétés une
émission que vous pouvez retrouver en
replay sur tv fil 78 points comme bonne
soirée à tous